accusations of censoring conservatives
Google banning right-leaning financial
blog zero heads from its ad platform and
warning the Federalists it could be next
the tech giant claiming posts in comment
sections violated its policies the move
apparently coming after NBC News
influenced Google to take action and
Republicans are responding with a new
bill that would allow Americans to sue
big tech companies over political
censorship the DOJ is proposing new
rules to limit Internet companies
liability protections Gregg I wanted to
start with you you've been in so many
formats of media throughout the years
and what is your take on all this why I
think this is how the woke crowd works
if you can't win in the field of ideas
you contact companies and reports what
you believe to be offensive material the
companies don't want the hassle so they
operate on a hair-trigger they'll do
anything to comply with this mob and it
actually is a fairly effective means of
silencing speech now people will say
this isn't silencing speech at all
because Google is a private company or
it's a company it's not a government and
nobody's telling you what not to say but
the fact is if your career in livelihood
is that the mercy of an intolerant woke
activism then it is silencing speech it
is it is harming you and this is
actually spreading out and it's really
frightening because you can see how the
media avoids data and statistics about
law enforcement in favor of polling
remember polling it aren't facts those
are those are gauging feelings but stats
tell you about behavior and we're not
hearing about statistics because the
media is so cowardly about it if they
see statistics as a third rail straight
to being canceled or being ruined and
it's a travesty because we need to know
the facts in order to push the ball
forward on issues like law enforcement
and instead we're just we're stuck in
like emotion and symbolism and virtue
signaling Dana what are your thoughts on
that new Senate bill so I think one of
the things I think that Google got
suckered by an NBC
Media hoax right so they have somebody
calling around saying hey have you seen
this in your comments and like oh no we
haven't seen it and then as Greg said
they were on a hair-trigger and then
they had a major public relations
screw-up so that leads to the fact that
you have on the on the left like aoc
congresswoman Alexandra cause you're
Cortes she wants the tech companies to
be regulated because she thinks they
don't do enough to suppress speech that
they don't like on the other hand you
have someone like Josh Holley the
senator from Missouri on the right
saying we want to regulate the tech
companies so that they won't censor
people on the right so it's weird Holly
and aoc kind of want the same thing but
for very different reasons and the
Congress I believe has had a little bit
of a light touch when it comes to
regulating the internet and big tech
companies because we like the innovation
we like the freedom I think we still
like the First Amendment but actions
like what happened yesterday or like the
concern that there was an action about
to be taken against somebody raises
everybody's hackles and I do think that
the tech companies are looking at some
sort of big reconciling in DC coming
soon Jesse how do you read all this
especially the reaction to the comments
not initial content can we defund the
speech police Emily I mean that's the
only police that the Democrats like I'm
really sick of these narcs the snitches
the control freaks these intellectual
lightweights that can't handle debate
they have to destroy you instead just
think about what they're doing to the
president on Twitter or any conservative
on Twitter you say something boom you're
cancelled I mean they sue the President
to stop his rallies I don't want to take
the taskforce briefings
you know they boycott Fox News they
boycott businesses they boycott
restaurants you can't even say anything
anymore all lives matters now racist
cops lives matters now racist they could
barely handle Merry Christmas
remember radical Islam oh my god you
can't say that you can't say anything
anymore I mean they're coming after the
clothes you wear
the maggots can even wear a t-shirt you
have to apologize
you like the anthem can't say that got
to apologize for that too or how about
the statues they're tearing down the
statues getting rid of movies getting
rid of mascots logos history pretty much
everything the left doesn't like they
need to erase this is just a Cultural
Revolution right now bigger than a
culture war and anything that they
disagree with they want to wipe out they
want to bankrupt you they want you fired
hell I mean if you work for the
president they throw you in prison and
while everybody is so intimidated and
scared by the mob the left is seizing
more and more power all over the country
they're not going to be satisfied until
they have absolute control and anything
they don't like about this country they
won't go on and the scary thing is they
don't like a lot about this country so
it's all on the table for them and
people better started realizing right
now this is a fight because right now
everything is on the table for
destruction mm-hmm one can you speak to
Jesse's points especially the one about
the canceled culture and about how there
are certain conservative principles or
even symbols that really have been
considered totally all right and have
now been you know essentially completely
canceled by the left to speak to that
please oh sure Emily I mean look I'm a
big free speech advocate you know I've
been fired for speaking my mind and here
on the five I don't think they're any
muzzles people can say what they want to
say and we go at it pretty good but I do
think that in this case you're talking
about a private company and there's no
First Amendment protection for a private
company they can select what voices what
opinions they want to feature on their
platforms that's America that's the law
and they have that right and I don't
think that we can say you must hear this
you must hear that and of course in
response to what jesse was saying I you
know I think that there are offensive
symbols and materials that other people
you know let's say the Germans they
don't have statues to Hitler there's a
reason for that yet we have Confederate
statues statues to people who were
traitors to this country to America who
wanted to break us apart I think that's
an indication of something out of
balance so to my mind I'm a Kazakh so on
this year but I think that private hang
on hang on let me finish please I just
think that when we think about private
companies again sounding like a
conservative I think we should stay out
of the business of private companies
making decisions that are best left to
them and their shareholders yeah those
decisions only affect conservatives
though that's the issue one that's not
true absolutely not true biggest media
companies in America Wall Street Journal
Fox's Rush Limbaugh censor your mob the
audience knows it conservatives are
targeted by big tech conservative
opinion in America